(Laughter)
And I was now writing the headlines.
My favorite one was,
"The stag trampled on my throat, and the press trampled on my privacy."
It was the most read piece of BBC News online that day.
And I was kind of having fun.
And by the end of my week of media,
I started to use my newfound voice and platform
to spread a message of love and kindness.
And when I had the minute of anger and hatred
towards those press and journalists,
I had to identify my inner bigotry towards them.
And I had to meet and speak with these people
without judgment.
I had to let myself understand them,
and in return, they began to understand me.
Well, six months later, they asked me to join the committee
that regulates the press.
And a few times a year, I sip tea and dip biscuits
with the likes of Daily Mail editor Paul Dacre, who says to me,
"So, Kate, how have your last few months been?"
And I respect them.
And I'm now one of three members of the public
who has a seat at the table --
not because I'm different,
but because my voice counts, just like anybody else.
And the irony is,
every now and again, I'm asked to visit those printing presses
of this declining industry,
because some people think
that the technology I spoke about here, last time at TED, my interactive print,
might actually help save them.
So beware of your inner bigot,
and make friends from your enemies.
Thank you.
(Applause)